hey dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to talk about fibromyalgia
I had several requests for it so I'm
just going to show you one of the many
things that I do and of course it's not
going to fix the whole thing but it'll
help improve the condition you're gonna
need someone to do it on you but this is
the video the training video of how to
do the procedure
it's an acupressure procedure that you
can learn sometimes it can create a huge
effect sometimes a very little effect
but I think it's well worth teaching
people that have this condition because
it's a very effective thing it's using
acupressure alright so a little
background there's two glands one is the
hypothalamus that's in the brain it's
deep inside it's actually if you go one
inch forward from the top of the ear
straight in you'll hit the hypothalamus
it's severe it's like the size about a
pea but it controls so many things it
controls the pituitary gland which is
the relay gland to the adrenals and all
these other things
now the pituitary is just just a little
forward to the hypothalamus okay so the
hypothalamus is the master gland the
pituitary is the middleman that's going
to then do some other things down to the
body so if you if you can associate it
with the owner the football team which
is the hypothalamus the coach which is
the pituitary and then the quarterback
which is the adrenal gland okay so you
have those Ashlyn's
that's how it works so there's two parts
of your body that you're going to be
working with with this technique but
just realize that the adrenal gland
controls the anti-inflammatory and it's
called cortisol cortisol is one of the
only anti-inflammatories in the body and
it gets through the inflammation but
this technique is not necessarily
working on that it's working on the
pituitary effect because the pituitary
also releases something else called beta
Dorf ins beta endorphins are not
necessarily anti-inflammatory they are
anti pain and they're probably 80% more
powerful than morphine so I'm going to
show you a way that I tap into it to
create a cool effect what you're going
to be doing and this is the back of the
head in the front of the head you're
going to be taking your fingers so your
middle fingers right here not not these
I'm not going to do that but these
middle fingers right here and you're
going to be rubbing at a certain angle
real gently kind of vibrating on this
point here in this point here you're
going to go one inch on the top of the
ear forward this way and right there and
then you're going to kind of come down
I'm going to demonstrate it on someone
just so you can see it and and then
while you're rubbing these two points
very gently you don't to do it hard
you're going to have the person either
touch a place that they have
inflammation or move a joint that's
inflamed so you have those two options
now you're gonna say well the whole body
hurts I understand that but just take
one part at a time so let's say we want
to take a wrist or a finger or a foot or
an ankle or the neck or the shoulders
you're going to take that you're gonna
have them move that joint as as you're
doing these points or pressing a sword
joint while you're moving the point and
you're going to ask them tell me when it
reduces okay more and more and more and
more and then you find the next spot
okay so let me just demonstrate how to
do this and you'll have more
understanding of it okay so here we are
we have the ear right here and then we
have an inch forward okay just about
looks like with of my thumb which it
might look thumb is very very wide so
we're gonna come right here and I'm not
flipping you off by the way and I'm
gonna come in an angle down this way
okay but I'm just gonna do that right
there I'm gonna do on both sides same
spot and I'm just vibrating my fingers
like this at 45 degrees roughly just
like that and you're going to do this
right two minutes
and you can stop and rest now what are
you doing you're activating these
acupressure points that are assisting
the pituitary and hypothalamus to be
able to release their own hormones
better and you might say well how do we
know what's happening well you'll see
when you do this technique you'll see
the results you'll see the inflammation
go down so you know it's something's
happening so it's just a technique that
I developed as part of my favorite
myalgia workup so you would vibrate this
right here at 45 degrees right here very
softly doesn't have to be hard make sure
you don't mess up the person's hair and
I like to vibrate it like that that's
the exact motion that I do right there
okay okay so as as he's bending his
wrist like he is let's see his wrist
pain and there's going to bend it right
there yeah and just someone's gonna ask
him while I do this I'm gonna ask him
tell me when it feels a little better
and it's gonna start loosening up if
it's really stiff or a problem okay so
he can move the joint right or he can
press on let's say there's some
arthritis on his thumb so go ahead and
press like on your thumb right right
here yeah and find a spot that you can
press so let's turn around like that
let's say he's pressing on this point
okay and I'm going to do this and then
tell me when the pain goes down okay and
then I'm gonna say find the next spot
and he'll move around find the next spot
I'm trying to get him to find the
epicenter of where the pain is while I'm
doing these little points right through
here at 45 degrees okay he can keep
moving it all right and then he could
basically let's say it's in the shoulder
so I'd say shrug your shoulders up and
down keep doing that for like a minute
and it's going to feel looser and looser
and looser and looser ankles you can
move those knees in different directions
you can press the press on a point on
your your leg or your ankle that's been
not healing and so go ahead and try this
technique out problem algid see if it
works for you
hope you enjoyed the video